[Musique]
m
aujourd'hui on parle de ça est ce que
vous connaissez cette boîte sont les
freebox 3 de huawei on est sur les
écouteurs qui sont plutôt cool que je
teste depuis quelques jours comment
cette petite boîte là qui s'ouvre très
facilement il ya plein de promesses qui
sont faits sur ses freebox 3 de la part
de huawei compact confortable qu'il sent
réduction de bruit intelligente et tout
ça avec la puce kirin a alors au regard
des ça on va regarder je vous dire si au
final c'est vrai est ce que ces web prix
buzz trois tiennent toutes leurs
promesses
est ce que vous pouvez faire exactement
3 vannes ou des critères intérieur on va
se faire un tour complet du produit on
va regarder si ton vraiment intéressant
qualité audio réduction de bruit confort
design
il ya beaucoup de choses à voir il ya un
gros éventail très intéressant d'autant
plus qu'on a une application qui existe
pour le gérer on va regarder points
forts de l'application point faible de
l'application la même chose pour ça et
au final est-ce que c'est free bird 3 à
189 euros 99 centimes valent le coup oui
ou non
[Musique]
non
regardez moi cette jolie petite boîte
comme elle est sympathique huawei
freebox 3 new intelligence en bon boîte
plutôt cool
on a un système à tiroirs ça je trouve
ça assez rigolo c'est pas mal il ya
toujours un côté un peu près bien
lorsque vous mourrez comme sa petite
boîte noire d'huawei bien up for
intérieur ça je les sorties complètement
ces planqués en dessous vous avez ici
vos écouteurs le troc est plutôt bien
vous venez vous avez toutes les docks la
charge là dans le petit guide de
démarrage vous avez toutes les infos
pour le prendre le brancher le charger
bon c'est assez efficace s'il vient vous
comprenez comment l'appareil est très
facilement nous le test fait ici avec
impétrantes pro pour le design plutôt
sympa petite boîte ronde plutôt bien
qu'avec le côté un peu chrome est comme
ça marquez ou huawei c'est assez
classieux ici vous avez de quoi le
recharger directement usd si vous avez
un petit bouton sur le côté pour venir
l'appareil est plutôt bien vous l'ouvrez
très facilement vos écouteurs se situe
là vous avez deux petits écouteurs qui
sont plutôt cool vous venir charger
directement dans votre boîte l'a bien
évidement et quant à eux ils sont
vraiment tous mignons tous sympas pour
trouver un petit bout chromé en bas avec
les micros qui vont se situer juste là
plutôt bien left right qui indiquait en
bas et vous avez d'applications qui
s'appelle own life qui vous permettra
complètement de venir gérer vos freebox
3 avec la technologie bluetooth 5.1 et
le processeur qui riina un web nous
promet que ses freebox trois sont
complètement optimisé pour l'envoi du
signal à savoir que ça vous permet
effectivement d'envoyer très précisément
dans chaque oreille le canal audio qui
lui est destiné à gauche
canal gauche à droite qu'à la droite non
dans le sens où apparemment
technologique du canal web the crown on
a également un processeur audio de 356
mégahertz nous annonce une connexion
bluetooth stable et rapide
c'est vrai que dans l'absolu je trouve
que ça fonctionne plutôt bien j'ai pas
vu de la tempe pas particulièrement ya
rien qui m'a choqué j'ai regardé des
vidéos beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup c'est
un grand consommateur joe smith sur
netflix
je me suis regardé des séries d ciani
j'en ai mangé pendant des heures j'avais
les yeux rouges comme un lapin qu'elle
indique son matos mais j'ai pas trouvé
de la tempe il ya une bonne synchro
entre l'image et l'audio il rien qui m'a
choqué de ce point de vue là pour moi ça
fonctionne la promesse est tenue
leurs termes d'usagés là dessus on va
effectivement sur du visionnage de série
on va effectivement sur du jeu si vous
êtes gamer si vous avez joué des jeux et
notamment sur smartphone bien coûter les
prius iii là-dessus fonctionne
parfaitement bien là toute une partie
sur la réduction de bruit et ça c'est
vraiment intéressant parce que en fait
ces écouteurs là ce ne sont pas des
intra auriculaires c'est à dire qui
à venir obstrué votre canal auditif ce
qui permet d'avoir une réduction passive
est ce qui vous permet déjà d'atténuer
tout le monde extérieur de vous isoler
vous rajoutez par dessus ensuite une
réduction active et ya quand même être
relativement tranquille mais justement
on n'est pas et c'est sur des intra
auriculaire donc ouais ouais enfin le
choix qui est relativement différent
mais que je trouve pas mal parce qu'en
fait on nous écoute au point d'y reposer
comme ça qui ne bouge pas et des intra
auriculaire on est vraiment entre les
deux parce que pour moi alors ça dépend
de la forme peut-être de votre oreille
mais pour moi en tout cas ils paul sur
mon oreille il vient légèrement le
boucher je le prends je le positionnent
comme ça directement dans mon orient ce
qui est très intéressant c'est quand il
bouge un peu parce que je parle à
nouveau comme ça vous change un petit
peu mais il dira quand même à l'entrée
en jeu patient va bien là les gens très
de l'oreille il vient quand même se
positionner ici et il ya quand même un
petit peu bouché l'entraînement n'aurait
certes d'une réduction passive mais très
très très faible ça dépend des oreilles
de chacun mais pour moi il va garder un
petit peu bouché le canal il est
vraiment à l'entrée du canal alors par
contre effectivement certaines
fréquences qui vont pouvoir passer un
petit peu par l'extérieur parce qu'il
obstrue pas complètement mais un petit
peu les produits jamais vraiment parce
qu'elle pas juger ma tête un peu comme
ça tous les côtés et je me suis dit ça
va pas tenir parce qu'en fait le confort
est vraiment là vous les prenez vous les
posez ils sont vraiment très très
confortable pour le coup je me suis dit
ça n'a jamais tenir comme ça c'est
impossible que les écouteurs comme ça
tienne et bien croyez moi aussi
surprenant que ce soit ils tiennent
tellement est plutôt bien vous pouvez
bouger alors vous avez pas pogoter
pendant des heures dans une foule mais
lorsque vous courez lorsque vous marchez
lorsque dans les ascenseurs dans les
escaliers dans le métro et croyez moi
dans les trous ya du bon et sa bouche eh
bien écoutez ça ça ne bouge pas et ça
c'est vraiment cool
donc on n'a pas une réduction de bruit
passive parfaite la réduction bruit est
pas mal mais on n'est pas au niveau de
ce qu'on peut trouver ailleurs mais sur
des scooters qui coûte quand même plus
cher pour voir quand même qu'on les paye
189 euros à 3,19 sauf que le boulot est
pas mal on pourrait vouloir plus on se
dira étaient âgés les écoutant avec une
réduction de bruit active
on va se dire ok je vais voir ce qu'il
ya de mieux en réduction collective je
vais les poser
ça me couper complètement de l'extérieur
et je n'ai vraiment dans ma bulle
sauf que c'est pas le cas donc là je
parle je m'entends parler à la fois un
petit peu l'extérieur et la fois dans la
tête ça c'est assez intéressant ça vous
permet quand même de couper un petit peu
des boys thalassa vous isole un peu de
l'extérieur pas sur toutes les
fréquences on va pas avoir pour moins de
200 euros 189 euros 99 le meilleur de la
réduction de bruit mais si vous voulez
acheter les prix baissent trop en vous
lisant je veux des supers écouteurs
adduction louis vont-ils être un peu
déçu parce que ce sont des écouteurs qui
ont la réduction de bruit active
c'est clair pourra pas se mentir ça
filtre quand même mais c'est pas
complètement il ya toute une partie qui
concerne la conduction ce alors à quoi
ça vous sert ça vous permet
so free bird 3 de retransmettre votre
voix avec plus de précision grâce aux
vibrations de voho le but est
d'améliorer le son de votre voix
la qualité de votre voix le rendu lors
des appels lorsque vous allez téléphoner
à quelqu'un tout en réduisant les bruits
environnants moi j'arrive pas le
quantifier directement lorsque j'ai
passé des coups de fil en face le second
était clair plutôt bon de quelle manière
est ce que ça intervient j'ai du mal à
quantifier mais en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que le son est ok par contre
au nom de la réduction au vent jusqu'à
20 km heure c'est vrai c'est pas mal
lorsque vous passez vos appels c'est
assez efficace est maintenant parlons de
la qualité audio
on a des transducteurs de 14 mm alors si
vous passez un peu le côté rébarbatif et
techniques quand on prend comme ça quand
vous le prenez flat vous prenez pas avec
votre smartphone vous activer la musique
vous mettez tac tac tac tac vous envoyer
l'audio ont un son qui est un peu médium
on manque un peu de base voyez sur le
bassin rond ne pas assez on manque un
peu de précision sur les aigus on a donc
un spectre qui demanderait à être un peu
rééquilibré que ça c'est le son de base
que vous allez retrouver vous est donc
dans votre application ou huawei ilife
et là vous y retrouvez ici pour freebox
3 ici je vois effectivement le niveau de
batterie mes écouteurs indépendamment
j'ai bien le niveau de batterie de
chacun j'ai le niveau de charge du
boîtier soit 55 % au niveau du boîtier
on doit vraiment où j'en suis je vois en
fait les raccourcis je peux venir
personnalisé mes écouteurs dire que
lorsque j'ai tapoter vous le voyez c'est
crissier à tapoter deux pas sur leur
gauche pour l'instant c'est activer
désactiver la réduction de bruit mais ce
peut venir choisir d'autres options lire
suivant lire mettre en pause active et
l'assistant vocal exactement la même
chose pour l'écouteur droit pour
utiliser mon acte il suffit de tapoter
deux fois sur la partie haute et ça va
actionner ce que j'ai paramétrer
directement dans mon smartphone vous
venez vous tapotez deux fois noise
cancellation of noise comme cela on a
mis des normes et une vision d'ensemble
sur la réduction de bruit tac jeunes
actives et là je peux venir ajuster la
réduction de cette molette elle vous
permettre de calibrer la réduction de
bruit par rapport à la forme de votre
oreille qu'on n'a pas tous les mêmes
règles ça c'est physiologique c'est
comme ça eh bien vous faites votre
réglages une bonne fois pour toutes
et ça vous permettra d'optimiser la
réduction de bruit par rapport à la
forme de vos oreilles et vous avez
ensuite la recherche de mises à jour
russie machisu la dernière mise à jour
donc ça fonctionne mais on peut pas
aller plus loin on pourrait se dire
mince dans cette appli manque un truc
qui manque vraiment quelque chose c'est
le fait d'avoir un équaliseur pouvoir me
régler ici il n'ya pas à mettrez votre
fonds eh bien non que nenni ce qu'il
faut faire si vous voulez vraiment
améliorée signifie
timidement la qualité audio il faut
prendre votre smartphone il ya des
réglages à faire directement ici vous
allez donc dans vos paramètres vous
allez dans son et là vous descendez tout
en bas et vous avez cette petite case en
basse et dolby à tous et là ça devient
vraiment très intéressant alors par
défaut il désactive et vous l'activez et
vous avez trois mages intelligent films
musique moi ce que je vous conseille
vraiment c'est de vous mettre en
intelligence et là ça va vraiment
devenir optimiser le son par rapport à
votre musique et ça c'est vraiment
vraiment bien vous avez un autre moyen
sinon qui est plutôt cool si vous voulez
venir paramétrer par goodman vous allez
dans musique
les équaliseur base ouvrir riche
focalisée pour moi c'est pas terrible
pour vraiment avoir une expérience cool
et personnalisé vous allez sur
désactiver et vous venez régler vous
directement voter quoi les arts
graphiques alors moi ce que j'ai fait
est ce que je trouvais plutôt bien
projet coûte du jazz de la pop quoi que
ce soit j'ai monté un petit peu avec un
pic de fréquence art 125 hertz la shop
boys and nash qui a creusé un peu médium
vers 1 kg et ensuite durement pour
récupérer de la clarté au niveau des
cymbales vers 8 kg et vers 16 kg sam est
clair si mon sens ça donne plus de
profondeur ça vient creuser un petit peu
les médiums et je trouve que
l'expérience est vraiment ils croyaient
pas comme ça ça me donne vraiment une
note dimension des coûte à vos freebox 3
le système de charge est double vous
pouvez soit seulement chez en dessous
juste là avec de l'usb type 7 fonctionne
sa recharge rapidement ou alors
directement son fils vous le prenez vous
le posez sur une base sans fil sa charge
ça va assez rapidement à savoir qu'avec
votre boîtier de charges vous pouvez
charger aux écouteurs jusqu'à quatre
fois
donc j'ai quand même relativement
tranquille on nous annonce à 4 heures
d'écouté en une seule charge alors j'ai
pas trouvé exactement quatre heures d
coûte en une seule charge
j'ai trouvé un tout petit peu moins nous
allons jusqu'à 20 en musique directement
à de votre petit boitier je sais pas si
on arrive exactement où jusqu'à 20
heures de musique en tout cas c'est sûr
que vous êtes a largement à plus de 15
heures de musique entre 15 et 20 à plat
et on va couper la poire en ou 17 50 je
n'ai pas quantifier exactement mais ce
qui est sûr c'est qu'avec les petits
frings 32 cannes relate une autre
enquête à charge vite vous commencez à
manque un peu de batterie vous les
mettez dedans de toi un petit peu pour
partie pour partager un peu de musique
donc bon le résultat n'a pas tant la
question c'est est-ce que c'est free
bird 3 de huawei sont intéressants oui
ou non ce qu'il faut se positionner au
pape il faut prendre la question peut
dans sa globalité on peut se dire ok on
ne vend effectivement des petits
écouteurs avec de la réduction brute
active
j'ai pas le top de la réduction active
au qui laisse une certitude mais par
contre il faut replacer le produit dans
son contexte pour repositionner par
rapport notamment à son prix on est à
moins de 200 euros on à 189,99 on va pas
avoir ce qui scelle not a le droit du
sombre par contre le bloc qui fait
derrière est quand même relativement
m mais par contre si vous les achetez en
lisant je dois profiter du meilleur de
la radio drs à l'aide des fûts dites
vous bien je vais acheter ces écouteurs
pour avoir les écouteurs qui sont
honnêtes qui ont une qualité qui correct
qui me permet en plus d'avoir un peu de
réduction de brunetti c'est à dire quand
même devenir diminuer certaines
fréquences et de m'isoler un peu un peu
dans ce cas-là ça fonctionnera on
pourrait se dire effectivement aussi la
qualité audio est quand même un peu
médium on va manquer un peu de pression
les aiglons m'a manqué un peu plus
grosse vie dont les basses et bien
rassurez vous vous prenez votre
smartphone vous activez le dolby atmos
vous avez profitez d'une expérience qui
sera augmenté d'autant plus que des pour
venir régler vos équaliseur à la main
moi je suis con c'est quand même ces
deux buts nous lui mode intelligent il
fonctionne quand même vachement bien
ça vous permet de profiter d'une
meilleure expérience sonore si vous le
prenez vous mettez de la musique vous
les mettez en flammes comme ça vous
allez vous dire ouais ok mais il ya eu
d'autres produits dont j'ai déjà parlé
par le passé qu'ils sont trop coût des
intrants et lorsque vous les écoutez
comme ça vous a c'est pas terrible mais
lorsqu on s'excite effectivement les
équaliseur et là ça prend une toute
autre dimension et c'est exactement la
même chose avec ses freebox 3 de huawei
vous prenez vous mettez le dolby et
mousses et là haut vous envoler c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant d'autant plus
qu'on peut venir après vraiment
personnalisé à d'autres expositions en
fonction du style de musique vous à
l'écouté
si vous êtes plus sur du hip hop movie
électro ne peut me caresser les bases
voulait monter un petit peu poseuse sont
là la précision j'ai fait que le pétrole
pro je trouve que les fréquences sont
assez film ça dénature pas le sont assez
naturel donc la qualité vraiment bien
pour vraiment devenir personnalisés pas
mal de choses l'étude je trouve qu'au
final on a les petits écouteurs qui sont
bien qui se tient quand même
relativement bien qu'il faut revenir un
petit peu customiser du côté de l'audio
la réduction bouille et honnête
aïe pop folk mais elle est là d' autant
la prendre la collection est très stable
j'ai pas notées particulièrement de
latence moi j'étais en tout cas assez
intéressant et plutôt bien positionnée
de ce que vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire comment voulez trouver sa
freebox trois doigts ou es ce que vous
avez trouvé interressant est ce que vous
les avez déjà acheté est ce que vous
pourriez vous positionner et qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces petits
écouteurs là ce que pourrait vous
laisser tenter
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire maintenant je trouve dès
demain continue par le tech vous
embrasse tous